this circular home behind me locally
known as rondavel
costs 200 round which is around 13 per
person per night
and is situated in arguably the most
picturesque place in south africa
the tron sky
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
morning baby thank you how was your
sleep
so peaceful
[Music]
this video is brought to you by my good
friends at
epidemic sound which is the greatest
sound and music library
in the internet in the internet okay
but more on them later
okay so what can thirteen dollars per
night in the toronto sky get you
more than you'd think okay before we go
inside i just
gab just got applause so i don't know
because she just had an operation so if
you were questioning
yeah that's why
[Music]
this insulated floor which is actually
made out of car shirt
countdown same thing
this thatched roof this light switch
this is however the only form of
electricity in this room
it doesn't come with any other plug
points the possibility to make new
friends because each room or dorm comes
with four beds
coat rack a dining room table a basin
a toilet an outdoor shower this beach
and this beach an outdoor meditation
room a local library
dining room area a self-service bar this
chill area
and this chill area the tron sky is a
250 kilometer long stretch of
unspoilt and rugged coastline along
sweeping bays footprint free beaches
lazy lagoons and rocky headlands
it is rural south africa at its best and
roads to the coast lead you through the
koza headland
a stunning landscape of rolling green
hills dotted with thatched round ovals
like the one we're staying in offering
interesting glimpses into a culture far
removed from the stresses of modern day
life
yeah i think that's what i love the most
that you forced to disconnect from
technology
ever since the first time i came here
this place will hold a special place my
heart
behind me he has what's known as the
hole in the wall and i'm gonna try and
catch a wave from
inside that hole it's ridiculous i don't
know why i've just
ever since i've been here i've always
wanted to try let me just contextualize
the significance of surfing through the
hole in the wall
the last time i was here around six
years ago with my friend ben
i attempted this with him and as i got
to the outside rock a wave knocked me
off
resulting in a big gash in my foot
wait what happened to your foot
oh that's been falling off oh that's a
bad cut man
pretty right through that got stitched
up later at a local hospital
[Music]
therefore i'm here now to claim victory
over this wave
[Music]
oh getting closer
i'm not gonna lie i'm pretty scared
water feels really sharky as well this
thing is what's
worrying me this big [ __ ]
tree trunk over here there comes a wave
oh my i just smacked back into that
thing
there we go
i finally did it i shockingly should
wave but nevertheless
i consider it done after this i went to
the bay next door to serve some proper
[Music]
waves
[Applause]
google earth got us stuck in a proper
proper pickle
look at this road it told us to go down
it's erosion the side of the grand
canyon down there
and we can't reverse either so we stuck
i don't know i reckon we can try and
drive down yet
this is going to be the gnarliest thing
i've ever done there's no ways we're
gonna get out either way
google earth is clearly telling me to go
down there
i'd possibly get through here but i
think you're back tired
oh then it's so [ __ ] you know that
section there is nowhere
[Music]
we've got reception we halfway down the
hill so we were wondering is there any
tow truck send you my location maybe
[Music]
we in the middle of nowhere do we risk
it thank you so much
okay bye bye even for people from the
lodge it's impossible for them to find
us
it's pretty crazy like there's so many
roads all over the place
it's getting dark
we now have a local here he knows what
he's doing which is good
because we don't know what we're doing
at all
he's going to try and drive the car down
slowly oh my um
hey there
oh man that was [ __ ] hectic
hey that's another thing that i wanted
to mention about the tron scott it's
just how incredible the people are
[Music]
insane
[Music]
okay the objective for today is to catch
a fish and my friend luando is gonna
help us do that
[Music]
[Music]
i've caught one fish before when i was
12
maybe 10. was this big
[Music]
no no no you've got to stand like this
are you crying i'm sorry i think it's
very cute that you cried
catching a fish have you ever seen
someone cry with catching a fish
very sweet she cares too much about the
animals
[Music]
thank you so much i think that drumming
was my favorite activity
more than fishing more than fishing
thank you so much really appreciate it
before signing out this vlog i just want
to tell you more about my really good
friends and sponsor
of this video epidemic sound and music
library
perfect recently they've extended their
sound effects library to include 90 000
high quality effects they also made it
really easy for me to save time while
searching for sound and music
by improving their tagging and
categorization both their product and
catalog
of tracks and sound effects is built
with you a filmmaker in mind so that you
can focus on what you do best
making movies if you support me go over
and support them too because they are
just so great
so yeah if you want to make better
videos by adding great sound and music
to them head over to the link in the top
of the description to get a 30-day free
trial now
and yeah that's our time here in the
toronto sky
it's been an amazing couple of days
don't forget to like subscribe and
comment
on the video it all helps it gets us
back up there on the on the algorithm
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you